[Music]
this is a very special song
going out to a very special somebody
we may not be together anymore but i
miss you more than the world
there comes a point in every man's life
when he thinks about
settling down
moving on from all the one-night stands
and the girls just messing around
wishing it was like the simpler times
when
romance was for life
so i asked my grandmother for
relationship
advice have you got any single friends
cause i like them wrinkly
if they're looking for a younger man
please tell them to ring me
[Music]
because i lust after ladies who are more
mature preferably
they've lived through both world wars
wrinkly i like them
ring please i met a gal called gladys
she said
hello hanson you're old enough to be my
great-great-great-grandson
she gave me her number i handed her mine
i had my first time having phone sex on
a landline
i love how her head so naturally white
and the only way she goes means if she
actually dies
there's no need to worry about meeting
her parents or getting pregnant cause
she's way past the menopause i
fell for her she fell for me but not
literally cause she's elderly she's
wrinkly i like them wrinkly
you can call me old-fashioned but i like
them old fashioned for i know
what's happened got a bra unfastened
they're
wrinkly and i like them ring clips
gladys draws the curtains like a
candelabra puts on a vinyl of sex jams
all frank sinatra
she takes out her dentures i take off my
shirt
she takes off her blouse and then her
medical alert
i try to hide my desire but it's
hopeless wanna jump her bones like
i'll steer peron she's had a double hip
replacement so i asked what should i do
she pulls me close and whispers let's
wear these ones out too
i'm a whipper snapper with senior fever
no need for silver foxes once i've seen
your silver beaver now we're
acting all flirty getting down and dirty
she's 99
so we her age minus 30. when we make
love i tell her back it up further
and after we're done i get a packet of
worthless she's
kinky and never so
wrinkly
i say to her gladys i'm so glad it's you
she says put it in me i'll put you in my
will
you and i were meant to be so empty
my vagina's like a time machine of the
last century
so i'll sing this song for you romantic
serenade dana
sing it louder because you lost your
hearing aid you're
wrinkly and i love you
wrinkly
gladys i love you and i miss you so so
much